More than that, if Cerberus is nearby
Heater
nande
[music]
goo
That's right,
I'm here
Cerberus seems to be safe I
'm glad
I don't have to see your disgusting way of wearing flowers.
What is this x earth What is this state?
If you do, you won't be
conscious.
I don't know
what you can do, but it's definitely different What are you thinking about in this emergency
?
No, anything is possible Miya-kun with a shelf is
like this, but even if you say something like that, def tee If you pull this root goo and talk, I wonder if different types will come out like the cord of a vacuum cleaner I wonder if
there will be a festival in the disaster area  I'm stopping it with a pledge If I just get it,
what should I
do now
?  Come and collect even the souls that don't come true
I always said Loveroy I was stupid for asking these people to stand up